hi there steve kaufman here and today i
am going to talk about
language hacking
and then specifically i'm going to talk
about benny lewis's book
language hacking a conversation course
for beginners italian all right in fact
i'm gonna hack
benny's book benny's hacking book
um okay where do i begin first of all
when i learn languages i buy books i
have always bought books i have lots of
books on language learning
this was one that started me on russian
teach yourself russian
so i have i'm quite familiar with
how these language books are organized
before we had link i would often say
that i would buy two or three beginner
books in order to cover the same ground
from different perspectives
and i can tell you that this russian
book for example i went back to it many
many times it's not like we go through
the book and then we know everything
that's there even though they promise
you that you will explore the language
in depth and
and speak and understand and all this
kind of stuff it's just a beginning and
yet there's so much there that you keep
on going back to it
so
benny's book on the cover
here
he says
learn by speaking right away okay so
right away there's an area where benny
and i don't necessarily agree
he feels it's very important to speak
right away
i don't think it's important i think you
should speak when you want to speak
however i recognize that a lot of people
want to speak right away
in my own case because i'm a very
experienced language learner have
learned many languages i don't need to
speak right away because i know that in
the long run i'll be able to speak but
many people who are maybe in their first
foreign language or second foreign
language they want to speak right away
they want some confirmation that they're
making progress and obviously speaking
right away first of all it enables you
to communicate right away if you're in
the country and second of all it it
gives you a sense of how you're doing
and it stimulates so it's it's it's not
a bad thing to do i just don't think
it's a necessary thing to do
then he says here embrace your mistakes
there's an area where benny and i
totally agree it's only through making
mistakes and forgetting and relearning
that we make progress
master power phrases he does that and he
does it very well in this book and i'm
going to explain why
and then he says do 20 of the work and
get 80 of the results
well it depends what results we're
expecting to get
but i do agree that he does simplify
things
now
let us go in the book what i consider to
be
very well done in this book
is that he focuses on phrases useful
phrases and doesn't overwhelm you
with
explanation
the
problem with the more traditional book
is that you start accumulating so much
grammar explanation
about a language that you're still in
the process of getting used to that it's
just overwhelming
and and that's why for example any of
these books you have to keep on going
back and going back to go back to things
that simply passed you by the first time
but i was very impressed on the you know
first of all simplified he simplifies
the explanation the pronunciation guide
it's like
one short little you can't really see it
but it's in that little box a lot of
books they'll go on for pages on the
pronunciation you haven't had enough
exposure to the language for that to
mean anything he simplifies he gets you
going i think that's good
in lesson one he gets you talking about
yourself i think that's very clever when
we're starting to speak and remember his
goal is to get to speaking early and one
of the easiest things for us to talk
about is ourselves
what we like how old we are where we
live and stuff like that
so
you know getting beyond obviously
bonjourno hello
how are you good day
uh
the basic phrase for talking about
yourself sono i am sono it doesn't sound
like a big deal but it's much better to
just say sono i am rather than
presenting the you know conjugation
which is again information overload we
don't need the full conjugation of the
verb to be so
you know
whatever
and then he goes very quickly on to
avoglio i want and me piace
is i like
he doesn't go into me is the indirect
object of the personal pronoun and piace
is the third person singular of
uh whatever piazza
or piacere
it's a it's a basic phrase that you need
and then
he has a very simple dialogue
and then he isolates these phrases
and again and this repeats throughout
the book you have some essential phrases
that are going to get to talking with
the english again no grammatical i mean
there may be grammatical explanation
behind it but up front you get here are
some phrases here's what they mean this
is going to get you talking about
yourself i think that is very good very
good
then he practice okay practice i don't
do practice so here again
language learning is personal
people do what they want to do
uh when i do these books i don't do the
drills the practices and so forth but
many people like to do them so for those
people
he has that if you want to do practices
you can do it you may not do it on the
first pass through you may go back and
do it later all right
he does have some additional sort of
grammatical explanations i find that
some of his explanations are are very
good
but some of the explanations may be
either unnecessary or they won't be
valuable to you until later so again uh
to me like
all right
again
seems to mean think but it thing right
but it doesn't it means what so you just
that's a phrase so if you look on his
phrase list causation what do you like
so he is presenting to the learner
sort of handy phrases that the learner
can start to use right away that is what
i think is very very good about
about this book
and again you know everyone has to take
out of it like and as i go through it in
every every conversation here he's got
some
very handy
phrases that would really you know that
you can use as hooks to get talking but
not only to get talking because
this these are also the key phrases that
you would need to understand as well so
i just think that he simplifies things
and you know he has a grammar
explanation combining two
verbs like voglio parlare i want to
speak
uh
the grammar explanation actually is very
short
mercifully sure mercifully short this is
again good like he tends to simplify
things so
my impression here is that that for
someone even for someone who maybe was
not necessarily interested in starting
to speak right away it gets you into the
language without the sort of information
overload that you get in other books
why am i talking about benny's book
because we are offering now at link okay
uh in
i guess it's german french spanish and
italian
five sample lessons from benny's
language hacking series
and these are free
now
i have said before
and i will say it again that people who
create language learning
websites like link
books
content
this is work they deserve to be paid for
their work that's why i always buy books
uh i buy ebooks i pay for them if i go
to a site where it's torrent free ebook
i never go there people who have taken
the trouble to produce something they
deserve to be compensated so
obviously benny and his publisher teach
yourself are making these available to
link with the idea that people then go
and buy his book which i recommend that
you do
i think that combining this book with
link where you can save phrases and
review them in flash cards you can do
dictation reverse flash cards uh you
know multiple choice i think this is a
very powerful combination uh if this
proves to be popular if this is
successful in combination with link
i hope that at some point
we can get
all of the chapters of this book
and if he's going to do more of the same
interlink but that's very much in the
future
so i think this is a valuable
contribution
different from to summarize different
from your conventional starter book in
that it focuses on getting you started
right away it minimizes the grammatical
explanation there are some other
explanations about you know customs and
culture and so forth which some people
may find interesting some not it's a
book that you will go back to and go
back to because in any of these books we
don't pick it up the first time but i
think it's a a
very valuable contribution a different
way of approaching language instruction
one that i think is very useful and one
i think one that i think is very useful
in combination with link so i look
forward to
hearing from you especially if any of
you have bought
or used any of benny's books i recommend
that you buy one thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you